Isis attacked Beirut in Paris one day
apart but why did the French city get so
much more global sympathy than the
Lebanese capital we asked people in
Beirut what they think I think there was
more angry about what's happened in
Paris because it's very like it doesn't
usually happen if there is now I'm about
it honey I'm right underneath journalism
attention can do not kill the blade i
know loserman wife's not here Paris is a
major city it's a much more
international city you look at the
people who died in Paris it's much more
ethnically diverse so you have people
from different countries who know
different people and therefore it's
easier to have this kind of global
solidarity over Paris enough certainly
in Hannes indiscernibly wanted in the
Hebrew the Bellagio is the same it's not
different when a matter of abortion a
menorah Tekken shield guard fool Harlem
of tránsito Allah Almighty that's a fit
issue a star attraction
wanna harbor no - Baron Musa wet been aa
Slavia been a European out an old actor
Roger Hobbs maybe say optimal Jerry
Martinez farm animal talkin after added
fella our team NB Beirut I think the
rhetoric towards the bombing in Lebanon
makes a huge difference
following southern Beirut that Hezbollah
stronghold it gets weird connotation to
it that makes it seem like you're
bombing a training camp or a weapons
facility or a barrack or whatever
unfortunately this kind of things happen
more in Beirut than in Paris and the
word is not used to it during this area
of the world where no one really cares
anymore just so normalized Allen blacks
listen Kenny tumble maldo I literally
I'm be seeing how I did do a lot of it I
see the fear my shaky lash and Enochian
O'Meara B&O and I know mama being on be
France how we will a detainee my can
suddenly start field will Beirut a ham
they're lazy minute inferior Christine
who Baghdad Baghdad ele Sofia
octarine Kim an elf division rocky on
our Sherrod 11s
you claw Akbar Muhammad Allah the Allium
Eleazar be sometimes the media that is
the utilize or put in an action when
when something happen in Europe or in
the water world is a little bit more
more global but I think from a humane
point of view people have felt the same
way and I get the same level both in
Bayreuth and both in Paris